the thing is this
it's the situation i remember when i got
out of prison
the guard said he'll see me again oh
right and i was like
who is he talking to
like
that's what you think like sarcastically
or like that's what he's doing he's like
no i'll see you soon i don't i can't
this is what i never do i don't i don't
assume
how somebody says i just listen to what
they say like
it
the statement is i will see you again um
that's i don't care if he was saying it
nice okay the statement is the words
that i'm listening to you took the words
i'm facing you again that means
he think that i'm coming back to prison
that's this that's clear mm-hmm
and i'm like
oh okay
if that's what you think
and
the anger but it's not my anger is never
misplaced energy like i place the energy
with so now my focus is i'll show you
that you and you'll see me again but you
won't see me in this place you'll see me
in a successful place yeah you'll see me
on tv you know
not even knowing if it was going to be
tv or not but you will see me again when
you see me
it will be in this from a successful
space i hope you remember that [ __ ] you
see how many years ago was that story
did that happen when i got out of prison
in in 1997. so that still
motivates you like you you don't just
like randomly think like that's the
story you reach out and that's in your
bucket ready to go nah if it's several
anytime anybody gives me
puts me in a box
and thinks that that's where i'm at i'm
like oh okay
and the
man this you're not going to be a good
father
whatever the statement is
like
i remember god told me that he was as a
stand-up that he was the same as me
i was like
i was like how so
he's like man i've done everything
you've done and in my mind like you
[ __ ] crazy
are you nowhere close to me
and i and i'm a person who never say any
of my accolades because i don't care
about them that those are things that
was done in the past that when people
come see you they want to see you right
now
but for somebody to say
and this is a new this is a new guy
this is a new guy
and that's how i think about these
youngsters
you do something on
instagram or youtube and whatever you
got four or five years in the game and
you think that you the same as me
okay
i'll show you better than i can tell you
yeah you
what you want to do you you want me to
go first you want to go first
because you can go first and do a hour i
come out and do one story and people
forget that you was there
that's just
it's like if somebody tell me that l.a
comics are better than houston comics so
new york comics the better he's coming
and i'd be like really what it at this
all it takes is me to hear it
and disagree with him like well well
let's see
if man if you challenge me in a
basketball game and you think in your
mind that i can't play cause i'm five
seven okay
the
if you block if you block my
three-pointer i want to see that [ __ ] um
anything if you like i see these gloves
up there anybody challenge me in that
ring
they gonna have a problem we're gonna
throw some hands with them they don't
have it let me ask you so you're a
pretty competitive guy yes um you're a
pretty competitive guy a former fleet
for soccer player ball player i used to
play ball um
you
it almost sounds like you use
the negativity and turn into a positive
yeah yeah i i misplace that in it i take
that energy and place it in the right
space you've seen uh you've seen the
last dance with michael jordan that
whole the whole document yeah uh
remember that remember the time when uh
his old point guard bj armstrong they
beat him one game he was playing with
charlotte i believe at the time yeah and
he got the best of michael jordan bj
armstrong who was nice little player
nice little point guard
nowhere near a hall of fame type career
they beat the bulls in game one and he
kind of
he he kind of gave a little
you know a little what's up to jordan at
the end and jordan and he did this
numerous times he told himself a story
that bj said i'm better than you
bj armstrong never said that
but michael jordan told everybody yeah
bj armstrong thinks he's better than me
i'ma show him and then proceeded to
destroy him jordan would make up stories
to
get to drive him nuts to feed the
madness because he was someone that was
motivated by madness
and essentially he would take that
madness and take that negativity and
turn into a positivity essentially the
same thing you're saying you're not
going to be a good father i'll see you
again soon i'm better than you i'll show
you just wait and see that's how i'm
kind of hearing what you're saying
yeah what i i totally understand mike in
the la i understand co i understand any
competitor
because you put things in your own head
to to
you could have said
somebody could say could have said nice
set to me one time
i never get to do that man you had a
nice set
and in my mind i took that [ __ ] all the
way like
what
what yeah like
who are you talking to
and
we still have we we have another show we
have another show
and he's hosting
and then
the who's i'm not gonna say who's
headlining but the headliner said
why you say that and he said well i just
told him he had and i said oh now you
just make this [ __ ] hard for me
because he's now he's gonna go out
and and i did i went out i got a
standovation the next set and i'm like
yeah that was that was a nice set wasn't
it like
what
was it was it
what is it
it's not even that people make him angry
it's that it's that even if you give him
a compliment
he will twist it got it so that he can
use it
just like jordan but it's like he said
it with something like like it was
unusual like
like i was out there doing it like you
that's your competitiveness
that's you that's you you said what like
it's unusual you know what you did you
did the whole you did the whole uh baby
you look great today oh just today
that's what you did to this poor dude oh
so it's today
what's what's what is it about today
is it the what is it the weather yeah
what is it today oh i washed my face
today like no other day
what made this one nice mr host
what was it about this one that got you
going
really
like i come out that's that's something
that i could see a basketball player to
do it too he comes out out of a game hey
man you had a great game
and you surprised
it's like
you said that to jordan jordan like what
you mean what are you talking about
but it's the same like
it's not just me i i run right so on the
track it's this lady
this is one white lady it's like every
time i see her ponytail it just it gets
it gets me going
and so
because the way she the way she run it's
like she run with this authority like
she a bad [ __ ] and i'm and i'm
and i'm like okay because on the track
this is what i do when i'm running on
the track
so i know i'm gonna do like three or
four miles
and
these people that's on this track are
not running against me they're not they
don't even know i'm out here
but i get in this mode like you in front
of me and i just i i don't give you a
half a mile for me i got to catch you
i'm like i'm going to run high as damn
i just locked her twice let me run her
down this white lady i ran past her and
all i did was this i ran past and i just
threw the peace sign
and she's on a treadmill no she's on the
track okay gotcha she's got a public
track that is not competitive at all
for no doubt she's not in her own
business i run faster
i just throw the peace sign to it right
and i tell you knock i hit the corner
and i'm gone i'm literally gone yeah
that's the first mile
first mile
by the second mile
this lady has ran past me and she threw
up she threw the juices your way
and that lady i didn't see her no more
like she
when i was done
on this i like i did like four miles i'm
on the side
and she she did she does like two more
miles i see this like she do two more
mouth and she comes by me by my truck
she said
i'm glad you decided to throw up the
peace sign
because that pissed me off hell yeah
like
she's doing it she needs the same fuel
to the fire like you she said and she
said you ran past me and i said
does he know that i run marathons for
like in her own mind does he know i run
marathons like and she does and i said
the next time i saw that lady she was
houston had a like a 5k or something
they was running and she was coming
through the ribbon with a she's like oh
no she running i was like
damn that's what's called playing with
the wrong person she's playing the wrong
person but it's see but the thing is
it's not just me yeah no i this this is
not supposed to make anybody mad this is
the peace sign
but there's there's some context there
it is i'm out
you're still in it you gave me the piece
let me ask you and i took that
personally what motivates you bro
because i don't think your same
motivation is him i don't think
that your motivation is similar to his
is it um no uh i'm more i'm motivated by
like
my mom you know what i mean like
the the
the aggressive
energy of like a
immigrant parent is kind of what drives
me i think what's the difference um i
think that you know
you're like i think everybody's driven
by probably by that you know he's
talking about kind of his mental
operating state which is a little
immigrant mother who only believe every
immigrant only believes in traditional
jobs
right right right so you're doing
anything outside of a traditional job
right you're wasting your time
what is what is this what is this thing
you're doing like the indian parent the
complex or the asian parent they want
them to be a doctor they want them to be
a scientist what have you no i want to
be a comedian and every parent wants
that and you motivate it right by
the
the image of you succeeding in something
non-traditional right and being
successful in it it's the same exact
motivation for sure i think my mother
motivators pat always talks about
do you have that can you pull that up
you think my mother
my mother
never thought
that comedy was the way
like
and
and when i tell people this and people
think that this that is
that you can't believe that i'm like
i never got any support from anybody
around me right because everybody
thought that
it should be something else i should be
doing something else
so just think of now
how that fueled me
to
like this thing i live in houston people
told me i had to move to la new york to
be successful right so it's more it's
just more fuel oh you got to get out of
here like man who
are y'all talking to like you talking to
a person that you think oh you think i'm
regular
so because other people couldn't do it i
can't do it are you losing your goddamn
mind like that's my it's the thought
it's the same
my mother
and everybody who i know you cannot find
one person that said
we thought he was going to do it you
know who who thought i could do it a guy
named rick that was in when i was in
prison
[Music]